el gobierno colombiano empieza a acceder
y propone cambios a la reforma
tributaria el presidente iván duque
ordenó al ministerio de hacienda a
construir junto con el congreso un nuevo
texto del polémico proyecto de ley con
el que busca recaudar cerca de 6 mil 302
millones de dólares para aliviar un
déficit fiscal la reforma no será
retirada pero se le harán cambios en los
puntos más álgidos que han desatado
protestas ciudadanas como el cobro del
iva a los servicios públicos impuestos
sobre el valor agregado que desde el 19%
que no van a haber aumentos en el iva en
bienes en servicios ni tampoco cambiar
las reglas de juego actuales en el país
eso quiere decir que en materia de iva
no va a haber entre otros iva adicional
o aumentos del iva a productos y
servicios que no se tocara la canasta
básica familiar de los colombianos que
no habrá iva a los servicios públicos
que no habrá iba a la gasolina no se
ampliará la base gravable el mandatario
colombiano agregó que
personas que actualmente no pagan el
impuesto de renta no lo harán segundo
que el proyecto busca ante todo
estabilizar las finanzas públicas y
proteger la calificación crediticia que
tiene colombia sin embargo a pesar de
una fuerte tercera ola de kobe 19 miles
de colombianos salieron a las calles
desde el miércoles para exigir el retiro
del proyecto consideran que afectará el
bolsillo de muchas personas con más
impuestos a la clase baja y media ya
duramente afectada por los estragos
económicos de la pandemia en este clima
de rechazo se suma el descontento por
los efectos sociales que ha tenido la
crisis sanitaria por kobe 19 que se ha
cobrado la vida de más de 73 mil
personas y que ha aumentado los niveles
de pobreza que según los más recientes
reportes subió al 42,5 por ciento en